l'astronome René Doyon et le
scientifique de l'année de Radio-Canada
il a conçu avec son équipe des
instruments exceptionnels qui
contribuent au percées du télescope
spatial James web découverte la
compagnie récemment aux États-Unis où
son équipe présentait ses premiers
résultats tirés des observations de web
c'est l'univers comme on l'avait jamais
vu des images grandioses d'une netteté
inégalée venue des confins du cosmos
ces clichés sont ceux captés par le
télescope spatial James web
lancer le 25 décembre 2021 est en
opération depuis l'été dernier et
transmet des données inédites
[Musique]
elle montre entre autres des milliers de
galaxies n'est tout juste après
l'univers il y a plus de 13 milliards
d'années
et aussi des galaxies en pleine
collision
une pépinière d'étoiles et même les
planètes de notre système solaire sous
un jour nouveau
tout ça avec une précision sans pareil
et c'est en partie grâce à lui
l'astrophysicien René Doyon
j'aime beaucoup aussi celle qui montre
la planète blanche
de mourir où est-ce qu'on a vu en fait
deux étoiles il y en a pas qu'une seule
savons toute la puissance d'observer
dans d'autres domaines de longueur
d'onde qu'on pouvait pas faire avant
contrairement à son prédécesseur hobol
qui captait surtout la lumière visible
le télescope James web lui est conçu
pour détecter la lumière infrarouge
invisible à l’œil nu un regard neuf sur
le ciel encore plus perçant que prévu
c'est une surprise même si nous si
scientifiques travaillons là-dessus
depuis des décennies là lorsqu'on a
aligné des miroirs pour avoir la qualité
des images de meilleure quantitative
c'est qu'elle était là elle est deux
fois meilleur qu'on s'entendait donc on
a vraiment une machine là qui fonctionne
beaucoup mieux qu'on pensait qu'il
fonctionnerait donc c'est au-delà de nos
espérances
le télescope est une collaboration entre
les agences spatiales des États-Unis de
l'Europe et du Canada
René Doyon est responsable scientifique
de la contribution canadienne qui prend
deux formes un instrument scientifique
appelé niris couplé à une caméra de
guidage le FGS le fine guidons sensor
assure la stabilité du télescope durant
toutes ces observations pour qu'il
fournissent des données extrêmement
nettes
une grosse structure ça bouge dans les
toutes leurs directions mais à
l'intérieur on le voit pas un petit
miroir près de cette taille là qu'on
appelle le stérile mirror qui est
contrôlé par la caméra de guidage du
canadienne qui permet de pouvoir le
basculer en temps réel cette fois par
seconde pour s'assurer que les images
sont vraiment bien bien fines
bien sûr embarquer des instruments sur
un télescope spatial ne se fait pas en
solitaire surtout quand on y a consacré
plus de 20 ans comme René Doyon
à l'Institut Trottier de recherche sur
les exoplanètes l'IREX qu'il dirige à
l'Université de Montréal son équipe se
réunit pour discuter des résultats
qu'elle va bientôt présenter à la
communauté scientifique
en particulier se fournit par
l'instrument canadien embarqué à bord du
télescope niris ou near in frered emeter
spectrographe
c'est un spectrographe qui décompose la
lumière infrarouge en spectre pour
analyser ses différentes longueurs
d'ondes
sa double roue contient des filtres et
des prismes qui modifient la lumière
selon le type d'observation souhaité et
les chercheurs sont ravis de ce qu'ils
obtiennent
l'iris en particulier lors d'un
transmission donc la fraction des
photons qu'on détecte du ciel et mieux
entre 10 et 40% là entre grâce à la
qualité aussi du de l'image du télescope
qui a les biens
ce qui intéresse particulièrement René
Doyon et ses collègues ce sont les
exoplanètes
[Musique]
des corps célestes en orbite autour
d'autres étoiles que la nôtre où ils
espèrent trouver des conditions propices
à la vie
des mondes qui pourraient ressembler à
la terre entre autres avec une
atmosphère
pour y parvenir les chercheurs utilisent
la méthode dite du transit quand une
planète passe devant son étoile la
luminosité de l'étoile faiblit
légèrement
sa lumière est filtrée par l'atmosphère
de la planète les experts analysent les
différentes longueurs d'ondes de cette
lumière filtrée pendant le transit et en
déduisent de quoi est fait l'atmosphère
de l'exoplanète
une mesure extrêmement délicate et qu'on
faisait avec avec robot avec beaucoup
moins de précision mais avec un
télescope beaucoup plus grand là on peut
observer des sites beaucoup plus faibles
donc c'est c'est un nouveau chapitre qui
s'ouvre
[Musique]
ce nouveau chapitre s'est ouvert
mi-décembre à Baltimore sur le campus de
l'Université John Hopkins qui héberge le
Space télescope Science Institute
plus de 200 scientifiques sont réunis
pour une conférence sur les premiers
résultats tirés de web les recherches
présentées sont souvent très techniques
mais il y a une constante la performance
remarquable du télescope
d
l'équipe de René Doyon participe à
l'événement
l'IREX a centré ces analyses sur le
système trappiste 1 à 40 années-lumière
d'ici une étoile une naine rouge
beaucoup plus froide que notre soleil
autour de laquelle orbite cette planète
la grande question que web veut répondre
dans les prochaines années est-ce que
c'est un être là ont une atmosphère et
de quoi est-elle composée donc les
instruments du web nérisent en
particulier et sont capables de pouvoir
faire ça et on est ici d'ailleurs pour
présenter les tout premiers résultats
donc on a obtenu avec Nice
certaines planètes du Système trappiste
1 se situerait dans une zone dite
habitable
ni trop près ni trop loin de leur étoile
avec des températures qui permettraient
d'y trouver de l'eau liquide nécessaire
à la vie
le but c'est de tout ça bien sûr et de
savoir ce qu'il y a de la vie sur ces
planètes là et pour le faire il faut
détecter leur atmosphère savoir si pour
vraiment en savoir c'est quoi les
conditions d'habitabilité on veut savoir
les conditions physiques y a-t-il de
l'eau et du méthane ou deux et
éventuellement même une biosignature un
gaz qui produit par de l'activité
biologique
[Musique]
James web a déjà montré qu'il pourrait
trouver ces conditions potentiellement
favorables à la vie extraterrestre dans
un autre système exoplanétaire was 96
sur une planète gazeuse très chaude il a
détecté une atmosphère riche en eau
parmi les longueurs d'onde mesurées par
l'instrument de l'iris ces pics
correspondent à la présence de molécules
d'eau dans l'atmosphère de la planète
was 96 B c'est l'atmosphère mais le
signal qu'on verrait c'est un truc plat
donc un paquet de points qui avec aucune
structure mais l'atmosphère on voit des
vagues et la forme de ces vagues là et
dépend de la composition chimique de
l'atmosphère donc s'il y a de l'eau il y
a du méthane ces vagues seront pas au
même endroit et donc non seulement ça
prend toute une expertise pour faire
l'instrument d'être capable de faire ça
mais ça prend aussi une expertise pour
analyser ces données là
jusqu'ici les chercheurs Montréalais ont
eu accès aux données de trois passages
ou transit effectuées par deux planètes
devant leur étoile conclusion ils n'ont
pas détecté d'atmosphères
détectés s'avèrent difficile à
interpréter les toiles est très active
et à cause de cette activité ça peut
générer un
signal atmosphérique fantôme qui n'est
pas réel donc ce qu'on découvre
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut apprendre
comment extraire un signal atmosphérique
très très faible de l'activité scolaire
les chercheurs appellent ça la
contamination stellaire la surface des
étoiles n'est pas uniforme elle contient
des tâches plus ou moins froides si on
mesure le transit d'une planète pendant
que son étoile montre des tâches la
baisse de luminosité mesurée peut venir
en partie de l'étoile et pas seulement
de la planète et de son atmosphère et si
les tâches ont de l'eau dedans on peut
potentiellement avoir un spectre à
l'allure de l'eau donc on prétendre
avoir des découverts de l'eau mais ce
n'est pas de l'eau dans l'atmosphère
c'est de l'eau dans les tâches de
l'étoile on était conscient de ce
problème là mais là on quantit très
clairement et on découvre que il est
différent d'une planète à l'autre il
prendra à cause de l'activité scolaire
donc c'est un problème c'est un gros
défi qu'on a devant nous apprendre à
comment faire ça discriminer les deux
effets
[Musique]
pour y arriver les chercheurs auront
besoin de plus de données
un étage au-dessus de la conférence le
Space télescope sciences institut abrite
le centre d'opérations de la mission
James web c'est d'ici qu'on contrôle le
télescope
la veille on a justement enregistré un
nouveau passage d'une des planètes du
Système trappiste 1 devant son étoile
une chance de plus de lui trouver une
atmosphère
on veut observer un petit peu avant
avant que la planète passe devant bien
sûr durant un plan de transit et après
et c'est ce qu'on appelle une visite et
donc le temps d'exposition effectif et
la durée du transit qui est dure à peu
près 3/4 d'heure une heure dans le cas
de ces planètes là et mais on sait qu'il
faut en accumuler les dizaines des
dizaines d'heures pour accumuler le
signal motivé très très petit qu'on
cherche à détecter
ont d'ailleurs souligné ces quelques 20
ans d'implication dans l'aventure James
web
[Musique]
une aventure qui ne fait que commencer
ces instruments ont été conçus pour
fonctionner une dizaine d'années le
télescope lui-même a assez de carburant
pour opérer pendant plus de deux
décennies
de quoi occuper encore un bout de temps
René Doyon mais aussi la relève qu'il
prend soin de former tout ce travail-là
ne peut pas se faire sans une équipe
puis d'ailleurs je leur en mange parce
que si j'ai cette distinction là
aujourd'hui c'est à cause d'eux et il y
en a tellement c'est la deuxième fois
que René Doyon est nommé scientifique de
l'année de Radio-Canada en 2008 il
partageait le prix avec David Lafrenière
et Christian Marois pour la première
image d'exoplanètes en orbite autour de
leur étoile depuis la recherche a fait
des bons de géants pour comprendre de
quoi sont fait ces mondes extrasolaires
la grande révolution qui s'en vient
c'est celle de mieux comprendre
l'atmosphère exoplanètes et ça ouais bah
vraiment ouvrir un nouveau chapitre là
dessus on voit déjà les résultats qui
sont absolument époustouflants donc
c'est un départ en gros canon là un
départ à Lyon
[Musique]